so let's not looking like 2020 summer
movie season is going to be much of a
thing but who needs it after all Netflix
has rights on hand to keep TV and movie
fans more than occupied over the coming
months here's the best stuff coming to
Netflix in May 20 20 left Lexus newest
action movies might be very different
but both are arriving on the very first
day of the month the first is son of
Thieves a 2018 heist film starring
Gerard Butler Butler portrays detective
big Nick O'Brien an LAPD officer tasked
with apprehending a squad of highly
skilled bank robbers two of whom
including their leader are former
Special Forces Marines when the crew
plans to hit the Federal Reserve Bank in
Los Angeles it quickly becomes a
cat-and-mouse game between detective
O'Brien and the gang and the good news
is that a sequel is already in the works
so now is a great time to pick up on
this one if you're more interested in
period action Netflix is also releasing
the Patriots on May 1st that said this
2000 historical fiction / action film is
less devoted to showcase in the era than
it is in Blowing lots of people up the
movie stars Mel Gibson as Captain
Benjamin Martin
a veteran of the French and Indian War
who was reluctant to join the
Revolutionary War despite being an
expert in the kind of guerilla warfare
the American army desperately needs
birth his son Gabriel inspired by
patriotic fervor joins the cause against
his father's wishes when death comes to
knock at the Martin family door benjamin
takes up arms one more time in the name
of revenge to become a legend of
america's first war may we'll also see
the arrival of a few sci-fi classics on
netflix first up for the first - Back to
the Future movies whether you're wanting
to revisit these beloved films or if you
somehow never seen them then there's
never been a better time to catch them
than now starring Christopher Lloyd and
Michael J Fox in the biggest roles of
their career the Back to the Future
movies follow high school students Marty
McFly and eccentric physicist dr.
Emmett's Doc Brown as they take off on a
wild adventure to the past and future
Back to the Future and back to the
Future Part 2 will both be available on
Netflix on May 1st
far on the other side of the sci-fi
spectrum is Neil Blomkamp's dark alien
invasion tale district
9 the film depicts the aftermath of
humanity's first contact with aliens
only this is no Independence Day these
aliens are lost and starving are quickly
placed in segregated housing and end up
being treated as pariahs when a
government employee named Vickers is
exposed to toxic material during a
routine eviction he soon finds himself
transforming into something less than
human forced to turn to one of the
downtrodden aliens for help
Vickers sets off a chain of events that
has devastating consequences for humans
and aliens alike district 9 will be
available to stream on May 15th May is
definitely the month of drama for
Netflix the streamer will be dropping a
bunch of self-made originals along with
many established classics if you want to
catch up on some oscar nominees you
could do worse than Trumbo a biopic
about the 1950's blacklisted
screenwriter Dalton Trumbo starring
Bryan Cranston there's also uncut gems
starring Adam Sandler in a surprise
dramatic turn as a charming but shady
jeweler these movies will be available
at may 19th and 25th respectively for
those who prefer Netflix's original fare
that may first arrive all the half of it
follows two teenagers attending the same
high school who Kindle an unlikely
friendship when one hires the other to
write love letters to a girl he has a
crush on as you might expect a love
triangle quickly forms which results in
one of the girls beginning to question
her own sexuality if you're after
something more vintage however there's
also urban cowboy which will also be
available to stream on Netflix on May
1st starring John Travolta this neo
western romantic drama is a little bit
cheesy a little bit honky-tonk there's a
whole lot of cowboy finally for
something that's just a bit different
Netflix will be adding the 2014 Irish
animated film song of the sea' on May
1st though it garnered widespread
critical acclaim and was even nominated
for an Oscar this movie didn't receive a
wide release and is generally regarded
as being hugely underrated it tells a
story of a young boy who discovers his
sister is a selkie a kind of half human
half seal creature and don't let the
family moniker for you either this is a
film that uses a mountain of symbolism
and deft visual storytelling to tell a
genuinely heartbreaking tale of grief
acceptance
healing any true horror fan will tell
you that a good Fright Night is suitable
for any time of the year and just
because those springtime flowers are
blooming doesn't mean you can't dive
into a good old-fashioned horror flick
at the beginning of the month Netflix
has two original features lined up to
keep our fans quaking in the muddy
spring boots
starring Jacqueline Fernandez and Manoj
Bajpayee mrs. serial killer is an
international film that tells the story
of a doctor imprisoned for committing
several horrifying acts of murder his
wife then sets out to commit a string of
copycat crimes to help establish a case
for his innocence there's always room
for some supernatural spookiness - and
if that's your bag then you're in luck
because Netflix is also bringing the
first three movies in the underworld
series to streaming this franchise of
horror action hybrid films concerns an
epic grudge match between vampires and
werewolves and sure they're not exactly
Oscar winners but they are a whole heap
of fun
everyone can probably agree that the
world needs a good comedy or two right
now
luckily Netflix has got you covered the
streamers may slate of laugh-out-loud
comedies should provide the perfect
remedy for these trying times on the
first of the month Netflix will drop two
flicks featuring comedy legend Jim
Carrey one is the 1994 comedy flick Ace
Ventura pet detective
fiction can be fun that same day
nothing's for at least another Jim
Carrey movie foam was Dick and Jane a
2005 remake of a 1977 film written by
doctor and superb art director Judd
Apatow if you like a little romance of
your laughter now flicks us a perfect
original feature coming your way mid
month the wrong Missy is a quirky WOM
calm following a man who accidentally
invites a woman from a nightmare blind
date to a work retreat in Hawaii so
relatable right of course for some
comedy fans one person spitting jokes
into a microphone is more than enough to
get the giggles going
fortunately Netflix has established
itself as just a place to scratch your
itch for stand-up and their original
stand-up specials have been coming hot
and fast for a while now May 20-22 be
any different on May 5th a comedy legend
Jerry Seinfeld returns to the stage for
a much-anticipated special entitled
23 hours to kill expect a fresh dose of
the comics patented brand of
observational humor include
hilarious musings on everything from the
merits of talking versus texting to the
timeless culinary magic of pop-tarts
later in the month and afflicted
releasing two more fresh servings of
comedy gold one from Patton Oswalt
subtitled I love everything and the
other from Hannah Gatsby entitled
Douglas Oswalt has been on the stand-up
scene almost as long as Seinfeld
but his offbeat variety of comedy has
really found an audience in recent years
Gatsby is a relative newcomer having
made a huge splash in the mainstream
through a 2018 special Nanette's
a new special is only her second and has
been described by Netflix as a grand
tour of guffaw that takes you from the
dog park to the high renaissance and
back into an unnamed box
finally Netflix will be releasing a
documentary about the life and times of
Saturday Night Live alum Darrell Hammond
inside sold cracked up with a Darrell
Hammond story just in case you're a
little tired at the standard part of
stand-up Netflix is dishing up a few of
its own TV series in May the first of
which comes from small screen guru Ryan
Murphy after rolling out his first
Netflix released the politician in
September 2019 Murphy sets out to a
while with his second entitled Hollywood
the series follows a group of young
actors and filmmakers trying to make
their way in a post-world War Two movie
biz and promises a savvy mix of high
drama and even higher style if period
specific drama is a really your thing
however Netflix is also releasing a
sci-fi Fast and we'll find Steve Carell
reuniting with his office pass Greg
Daniels space forces a workplace comedy
featuring corral commanding the would-be
space bound brand to the military and
fronting a killer leading cast featuring
a lineup of comedy greats there are also
a handful of network gems hitting
Netflix in May 20-22 fam ungdom is a
fourth season of the CW's teen drama
thriller Riverdale which saw the series
push its absurdist aesthetic father than
anyone could have anticipated Grey's
Anatomy fans will likely want to keep an
eye out for season 16 s Netflix arrival
to those episodes will be available to
stream on May 9th while may 2021 see the
arrival of genuinely exciting films to
Netflix
it'll also see the departure of some
genuine cinematic gems the good news is
that not much is actually leaving
Netflix until roughly mid month and
fortunately the movies are leaving are
among the
best on Netflix at the moment these
include the brainy Bradley Cooper LED
thriller limitless and 2012
tragically overlooked crime a peg the
place beyond the pines there are a
handful of equally underrated flecks
making their Netflix departure just a
few days later among them a Black Snake
Moan a bizarre social drama starring
Samuel Jackson and Christina Ricci which
heads out on May 19th also leaving
Netflix a day as Jason Reitman scrin gin
juicing dramedy young adults which
features Charlize Theron as a why a
fiction author desperate to rekindle her
romance with a high school sweetheart
for those looking to revisit a couple of
90 0 classics you've got until the end
of the month to get your swing gone with
Mike Meyers pitch perfect spy spoof
Austin Powers international man of
mystery and its subsequent sequels he'll
be and that's dates over 1993's Johnny
Depp and Leonardo DiCaprio starring
indie flick What's Eating Gilbert Grape
finally if you're among the die-hard
fans of the death-defying final
destination horror franchise the first
three films in the series will
officially leave Netflix on the 31st
that's with the movie's side of things
now flicks was about to holla
last call on a handful of notable small
screen offerings one silver lining that
can be found however is that most of the
shows leaving Netflix in May 2020 are
either old or recently cancelled if you
love to carry washington's twist a
minute political thriller scandal you'll
want to mark may 18th on your calendar
that's the final day you'll be able to
revisit all 124 episodes of the series 1
of USA Network's best love series the
medical drama Royal Pains is also slated
to leave Netflix on May 17th status
savour however is the imminent departure
of Bob Russ from Netflix is streaming
service rasa soothing voice and stunning
artwork have been just a ticket for
generations of TV fans and thought to be
a great tonic for these difficult days
sadly the first collection of Russia's
beloved painting series beauty is
everywhere is set to leave Netflix at
the end of May
start your binge now while you can
because you just can't have enough Bob
Ross in your life check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and at the Bell
so you don't miss a
go on
[Music]